the Democratic presidential candidates
hold their next nominating contest today
in Nevada latest poll shows Bernie
Sanders holding a double-digit lead over
the rest of the field Nevada is the
third state to hold a primary or caucus
this election cycle and after finishing
at or near the top in Iowa and New
Hampshire Sanders campaign could get
another big boost today ed O'Keefe is in
Las Vegas
mr. o Keith good morning good morning
mr. klore already 75,000 people have
cast ballots early in this state that's
almost as many as caucused four years
ago and despite the rain around
lunchtime today Nevadans will head to
high schools libraries and yes even some
of the hotels here on the strip to cast
ballots in this race but it's one of the
candidates who's not competing here in
Nevada who's facing some scrutiny and
making some changes Mike Bloomberg under
intense pressure to release former
employees from non-disclosure agreements
former New York Mayor Mike Bloomberg
says his company will allow three women
once signed NDA's over comments he made
to speak out if they choose in a
statement he said I recognize that NDA's
promote a culture of silence in the
workplace and contribute to a culture of
women not feeling safe but some
opponents say Bloomberg needs to do more
if he wants to be the Democratic nominee
he's going to have to be fully
transparent Bloomberg is it competing in
Nevada and candidates who are like
former Vice President Joe Biden spent
Friday looking for last-minute support
look the good news is the field is
narrowing the better news you're all
taking really closer looks at the other
guys now not bad folks are just not
Democrats but polls here give Bernie
Sanders a comfortable lead the senator
is so confident of his chances in Nevada
that he spent most of Friday campaigning
in California which doesn't vote until
next month
I got news for the Democratic
establishment they can't stop us
opponents like mayor Pete Buda jet
worried that Sanders a self-described
Democratic Socialist will end up
alienating four to many voters he is the
front-runner right now by many measures
I'm the only candidate who's beaten him
at all and that was by the slimmest of
margins in the delegate count in Iowa we
need to ask ourselves as a party whether
we want that to be how we compete
against Donald Trump or whether there's
a better way I'm offering a better way
okay which candidate has the most to
gain and or lose in this caucus well
Michele obviously if Bernie Sanders
pulls it off here again it just adds to
his momentum and his case to win the
Democratic nomination it'll send chills
down the backs of more moderate
Democrats who worry about a
self-described Democratic Socialist
becoming the party's nominee but
probably too with the most approve Joe
Biden and Elizabeth Warren who weeks ago
we're seen as powerful likely contenders
for the nomination and have struggled to
find support in Iowa and New Hampshire
if they could come in second or third
here in Nevada it would certainly help
at a record number of people as you know
watch the debate on Wednesday night 20
million is there a sense of which
candidate is going to be able to harness
their performance in that debate in to
support tonight's well support here in
Nevada not necessarily the one that
probably faces the most question still
about what went on in that debate is
Mike Bloomberg
who of course isn't competing here in
Nevada and will making his next
appearance in our South Carolina debate
next week
beyond him it'll be interesting to see
if someone like again Warren or mayor
Buda Jets perhaps do better than
expected here in Nevada and if that had
anything to do with their debate
performance remember in New Hampshire
senator Amy Klobuchar had a great debate
performance a few days later placed
third unexpectedly something like that
could happen here as well and so much
early voting there - ad which may have
an impact on that as well now we we know
what happened in Iowa with a caucus so
what's the Nevada
Democratic party doing to ensure these
results in the caucus are reported
correctly well for one thing they're
using a combination of iPads and Google
Documents to do the math today so while
that might mean it's more efficient it
also could mean there's potential for
math and technology problems similar to
what we saw in Iowa the party had tried
to make some changes here after seeing
what happened in Iowa but there's still
concerns that precinct captains and
others running the caucuses across the
state might not be able to use that
software or that there could be delays
don't necessarily presume that we'll
have results by the end of today it
could bleed into tomorrow that's typical
that sometimes takes a little longer to
count here but it would cause concern
for Democrats nationwide if in their
first three contests two of them took a
while to do the counting there is no
doubt ed O'Keefe always a pleasure thank
you